okay all right
there it is the president saying he has
made a decision about whether to pull
out of the Iran deal has not revealed
that he said to let us know when he
wants to joining us now to discuss that
and a lot more as the president's
national security adviser HR McMaster
sir pleasure to have you on the show
Thanks thank you for your service to the
country ultra privilege so do you
Rex Ellison Secretary of State was
surprised to hear that the president
said that he had made a decision did you
know that the president had made a
decision sure we've all been involved in
lengthy discussions not just about the
Iran deal but really what to do about
Iran's destabilizing behavior broadly
you know the the the the potential of a
nuclear program the need to block all
paths to a nuclear weapon for Iran but
their ballistic missile program things
not covered under this incomplete deal
and really what they've done to
perpetuate violence across the Middle
East with support for terrorist
organizations proxy forces propping up
this murderous Assad regime you know
causing problems and enmeshing people in
conflict in in Yemen's subverting Iraq
and so we've taken a holistic look at
this I think what's different about the
president's approach is that he didn't
look just at the Iran deal he placed his
decision on there and deal in broad
context of how we protect American
citizens American interests how we
protect our allies and partners from
Iran's broad range of destabilizing
behavior understood two questions one
what is the decision do you know I know
what the decision is but but but when
when the president reveals that when he
talks about it he'll place it in context
of the broader approach to Iran and what
we have to do as a nation to protect our
people but what we have to do with our
with our allies and partners to really
to really prevent Iran from continuing
this buried to stabilizing behavior the
threat to Israel the the the seeding the
the flow of these of these very
destructive weapons through this
clandestine network they've set up you
know from from you know Gaza to Levin
to Syria to to Yemen and understood in
Iraq dangling it the way the President
did is good showmanship perhaps but it
can also be destabilizing you had
rouhani from Iran come out and say this
deal is non-negotiable you had Khomeini
understood he's a religious leader he is
prone more towards extreme views he says
that the president is speaking at a
desperation and anger the central focus
is I hear everything you said about what
Iran is doing and we've heard it from
others as well that is not what this
deal was about as you well know this was
about controlling containing as best you
can
looking at the missile program the
nuclear development program why mess
with that deal in the interest of these
outside issues well I think the main
reason is the deal is fundamentally
flawed I mean it as the president said
he called the worst deal of all time it
gave the Iranian regime all the benefits
up front and then the incompleteness of
the deal the flaws of the deal the
sunset clause that could really give
this regime who's not trustworthy
obviously cover to advance a nuclear
program and then have this threshold
capability but you had the 60 lb
missiles which lie outside the
understood Ram but you have a visit that
issue here and you have your six nation
allies okay including the US this was
the best deal they thought they could
get by most accounts this has stopped
slowed and somehow in some way
positively influenced their development
capabilities and we haven't heard you
guys Rex Tillerson or others question
that reality but if this was the best
deal they thought they could get and you
have outside concerns why not deal with
those separately cut a different deal
about what Iran is doing elsewhere
assuming you have leverage but if you
mess with this you may destabilize the
entire situation according to the
Iranians well what's happened is this
deal has had the exact opposite in terms
of what the expectations were the effect
of that deal and Iran is continuing
missile development missile development
that could be paired with the nuclear
program later the the regime has not
just walked up the line but crossed the
line you know spinning too many
centrifuges too much heavy water and so
while the IAEA the the monitoring body
has
has called them out on it and they've
corrected some of this how do you trust
this regime to do it so much more
rigorous enforcement is needed the need
to address this fundamental flaw of the
sunset clause the need to address other
capabilities that could then threaten
the world from this autocratic
theocratic regime in in Iran and so such
as the missile program so these are the
things that we have to work on together
but in the context of an overall Iran
strategy because Iran is is
destabilizing
not just the Middle East but poses a
broader threat Iran is is perpetuating
this humanitarian and political crisis
in the Middle East I don't think the
argument is so much about what Iran does
that as negative it's about how to
approach it because in this move
potentially you destabilize a second
situation which is North Korea because
arguably what we've been hearing from
most of you guys when the president
isn't being more inflammatory with his
rhetoric is we'll get them to the table
we'll make a deal why would North Korea
make a deal with people who are backing
out of a deal with somebody else
involving nuclear capabilities doesn't
it compromise your efforts there no I
don't I don't think so at all in fact I
think it's strengthens our efforts with
North Korea cause North Korea knows this
president is not going to repeat the
failed strategies of past but help us
understand how North Korea seen you back
out of a deal with six nations involved
helps well what's happened is North
Korea has just walked into deals with
the North Korean regime which it then
breaks immediately so the pattern in the
past with North Korea was to engage in
long drawn-out talks lock-in wherever
they had gotten with their missile
program their nuclear program is a new
normal and then a week deals developed
which then Iran immediately break I mean
I'm sorry North Korea immediately breaks
so we're out of we're out of time now on
North Korea so we can't take that
approach anymore and what the
president's been able to do is is
marshal the the broad community of
nations nations who recognize that we
must work together
urgently on this problem and so you've
seen the very strong sanctions - 15 -
nothing votes in the Security Council
now the move to enforce those sanctions
and do more the president will make an
important announcement today about the
continuation of our efforts to resolve
this problem with North Korea
short of war and he'll make that
announcement as he meets with our very
close allies South Korea and Japan lady
one of the authors of rocket man as a
way to describe Kim jong-un do you think
that kind of rhetoric helps well it's
it's an accurate term I mean this is
someone who was compromised everything
for his nation in the pursuit of this
capabilities he is he is disadvantaging
his own people every day by investing is
what the president said a suicide
mission
this is not going to keep his people
safer it puts them on a path to
devastation understood what does the
words matter
edik t' apply here that you know you
talk to a hothead who's very unstable in
an inflammatory way is that helpful well
it got everybody's attention right and
we need to get everybody's attention we
cannot take the same approach we've been
taking on North Korea it is really
really an urgent problem though so
there's talk and then there's action you
have been talking about something called
preventative military action okay which
is different than pre-emptive and this
isn't you know I'm not trying to get big
brain on this it matters to the American
people yes pre-emptive is who they're
getting ready to do something to us and
we can see it we have to do something
first recognized an international law as
a reasonable potential basis for act
preventive is not you've been using the
word preventative what do you mean by
that what would you do with military
force well preventive means that you
think that the threat is so grave and it
is so imminent that you have to act to
prevent that threat to the American
people that's priam or Alice know
pre-emptive is if you see that an
imminent threat so for example the
lining up of missiles that could be
tarred and this is this is a leader who
said he is and his people have said he
is going to target the u.s. understood
us the great threat to our great ally
Japan and obviously South Korea which
lives really under the gun of this
regime and about 50,000 US servicemen
and women and their families right and
and so what we owe the president is
options what we have to do is help
define with our great intelligence
community along with our South Korean
allies with our Japanese allies to
define these decision points because
there may be some really really tough
choices now everybody wants to resolve
this short of military conflict
everybody knows
how costly that could be how
unpredictable it is once you begin this
interaction and military interaction
with this kind of a regime so why don't
we talk about it so much because we have
to have these options on the table a few
how do we have options yes we do have
options certainly we have options do you
think one of them would be shooting down
one of these missiles it could be there
a broad range of options that we have
available you know we have tremendous
military capability along with our
allies we practice that capability we
have our forces at a very high level of
readiness and an increasing level level
of readiness for this problem but but
what the president has done is he has
directed us to integrate what we're
doing diplomatically what we're doing
economically and with sanctions with our
plans and what we're prepared to do
militarily if you divorce what you're
what you're prepared to do militarily
from your diplomacy your diplomacy is
it's not going to be effective right but
at the same time to talk about will
totally destroy look we get the idea of
muscular rhetoric we get it but you are
dealing with a madman and don't all
Rhodes of any kind of military action
lead to great vulnerability for 10
million people in Seoul and all of those
American lives on the DMZ of course they
do every time we talk about this the
president first talks about the South
Korean people and the importance of of
us of us solving this problem in a way
that that doesn't that doesn't involve
the increased risk to our great allies
there but the president's ret rhetoric
was completely appropriate because
what's even more dangerous if there's a
lack of clarity previous presidents as
you know have made very similar
statements and the clause is that if you
know if if if North Korea attacks if
North Korea right takes these
provocative actions we may not have a
choice so that's the same standard that
it's always been you ever change the
line it is it no but the line of code
that you know it's it's much more
dangerous than ever though understood
because of the way this program has
progressed over the years what they're
doing previous previous agreements have
failed what they're doing has changed
but you're saying our standard the
United States standard for military
action has remained the same in terms of
what you'd have to perceive as threat
well and what we get what we're what we
have to do at this point is provide even
more options we have to work harder at
be sure we're ready for any eventuality
I mean this is a nation that poses a
grave threat to the world right if a if
a missile can reach the United States it
can reach other nations as well under
stiff if the non-proliferation regime
which means you're preventing other
nations from getting nuclear weapons in
a way that could destabilize the world
if that breaks down if you have if you
have Japan really arming if you have
South Korea arming at a higher level
which they're doing they have to that
that's that's destabilizing to the
region to the world and it's a threat to
all nations and so so the president has
called on all leaders our allies and
others including China Russia others to
do more understood the Russia
investigation I've been hearing you this
morning saying you're focused on other
things but it is a national security
issue that which Russia was doing to
impede our election it just is by
definition what do you feel about the
implications of what Russia did and do
you endorse what the special council is
doing well what we have done for the
president is we have developed a
strategy for for coping with Russia and
secretary Tillerson is in the lead on
this and essentially what we have to do
with Russia is three things we have to
confront their destabilizing behavior
the president is going to meet with
President poroshenko of Ukraine today
whose sovereignty has been threatened
and is under threat today from from
Russia the second thing that we have to
do is though we wanted to deter conflict
with Russia right this is a
nuclear-armed nation we've you know we
had the long cold war with the Soviet
Union we wanted to turn further
conflicts in areas where we are
interacting with with Russia we have to
make sure that we keep that in mind as
well but the third thing we want to do
is find areas of cooperation where we
can work together in our mutual
interests what we've seen in recent
years is Russia it does reflexively
anything they can to disrupt United
States interest to disrupt the interests
of our allies that's really silly okay
we should be able to work together in
some key areas surgery Torsten I think
has done a magnificent job in finding
some areas to cooperate with in Syria
for example to address that humanitarian
catastrophe there in a way that's
consistent with our long-term interests
and really denying Iran
this so-called land bridge that could
put an Iranian proxy army on the border
of Israel I mean this is there are big
big issues that we could use Russia's
help
we saw the story maybe today about how
Russia might be transshipping - yes
North Korea that's not in their interest
so we have to find these areas of
cooperation with Russia even as we
confront their destabilizing behavior
just to be clear on the record there I
want you to have the opportunity for
this the questions about what they did
who might have helped them and how to
stop it you believe those are all
legitimate questions for us to look at
of course and so does the president hmm
he's been he's been in different
positions on that issue but I want you
on the record on it thank you very much
for being with us Chris great to be with
Richard you're always welcome here on
new day to talk about what matters to
the American people thanks Chris